uh
so
yes this is the second talk and uh what
i'm gonna do now is talk about
how to use some of the machinery from
last time and then uh combine it with a
bunch of graph theory in order to
actually get fast solvers for laplacian
systems
so
uh and by the way and by the way just uh
just to see where this is situated uh so
next the next one i'm going to kind of
sometimes start over and not use
anything from the first two talks and
get another approach
um but i think that this one so this one
is really strongly connected to last
lecture
um i if people weren't here for the last
one and have questions feel free to
or if i just kind of assume things i
shouldn't feel free to like wave your
hands and ask questions yeah great
question about the last lecture right
the um chevy j polynomial stuff is that
related to momentum walks are in there
yeah that's actually a really good thing
the answer is yes so um
the question was there's these iterative
methods in the sort of just straight
context optimization world not
um
linear system solving but just broadly
speaking i give you some convex function
that you want to minimize and i give you
some properties and some promises and
there's this you know the gradient
descent analysis gives
some value that depends on some
parameters lipschitz constants and
strong convexity and whatever else and
then there's this beautiful paper by
nestarov that shows that you can take a
square root of something there
and it is actually the same square root
for a reason that i think i'll answer
offline
roughly speaking if you apply
yesterday's method for that's this is
the momentum things you were talking
about right am i answering the right
question
um so it turns out if you apply those
to minimizing the quadratic function
that i wrote down last time
you actually do get the same behavior
and you essentially get the chebyshev
polynomials
so nestorob's method does give a
three-term recurrence relation that
isn't quite javascript it's like
slightly conservative chebyshev so if
you were to take chebyshev polynomials
and just kind of back off the parameters
a little that actually is what you'd get
if you were to work out what restaurants
method does
so it is um
but i
maybe i'll answer offline exactly how
that works uh roughly speaking nestrob's
analysis
just that sometimes if you look at what
it's doing it's using more or less the
fact that a strongly convex function is
boundable by a quadratic in one on one
direction by a line on the other and the
quadratic the strong convexity constant
is exactly the
uh condition number that we're writing
down so it does actually match over
uh but maybe i'll answer more about that
offline
other questions
okay so um let's get started on this one
so last time i talked mainly about
generality sort of every i think
everything was before 1970 that came up
in the last lecture today we're going to
jump forward to the 2000s and um i'm
going to specialize the methods from
last time which were almost entirely for
general systems to solving laplacians
and there's actually a very long history
on this that i can't do justice to and
so what i'm going to do is just give a
super short summary of it just to say
where what i'm talking about is coming
from and then i'm going to post some
links
just so that you actually have the full
versions of what i'm saying and so that
i don't i don't know inadvertently
slight dozens of people and so i'll um
or
yeah so i'll i'll post some links online
and
i'll find out from the organizers have a
link to my links okay so the very short
list of what's happened in the past on
philosophy and systems was you know
there's a lot of work on solving various
subclasses because they come up a lot in
practice
but the ones that have come up a lot in
certain practical settings had certain
special structure you know they came
from triangulations of
low dimensional objects and so there
were a lot of special cases that have
been solved very efficiently
in particular if you hear the word
multi-grid it's almost entirely
referring to solving
certain classes of
laplacian systems
and then of course you could do general
direct solvers like ascii elimination or
strassen's algorithm
there's gener general iterative solvers
which we talked about yesterday
um and then for graph laplacians that
was sort of where the numerical analysis
um toc kind of line got crossed a bit in
the theory of computing community
recently there's been a long line of
work that's led to nearly linear time
algorithms based on recursive
preconditioning and that's what i'll
talk about today uh this line of work
was my knowledge started by vaidya who
put in place sort of the general
structure of using the combinatorial
properties of a graph to construct
preconditioners and this was continued
by
a lot of people in this room and others
and
it led eventually to the first nearly
linear time algorithm by dance billman
and xian watang which really started i
think uh a recent speed of papers
and that built on a whole string of
intermediate papers that i'll post some
links for
um and then this talk i'm going to talk
about a
paper that followed it which was by gary
miller janice kudis and richard peng
which uh very much sped up the linear
algebra the newly linear algorithm and
also vastly simplified it it was based
on some of the same ideas but included
some very beautiful ways of
redoing
a good chunk of the structure to really
simplify what was going on and lead to
an algorithm that actually will work on
a real computer
um so you know the skill and tag
algorithm they were really shooting for
the theoretical result and didn't try to
optimize the numbers of logs and
constants but they were large you know
it was
30-ish
logged the 30 and constants that were
very similarly large um i'm sure that
their method could have been pushed down
a little bit if they really tried to
optimize the number of logs but it
wouldn't have been a small number and
then this has two and then gary richard
and janice had one and now more recently
they've gotten it down to a square root
of to a half of one um so okay so
subsequently this has been sped up
further and i'll post the links to it
the one i picked was one that has i
think a nice trade-off it's a very
reasonable number of logs analog squared
n uh and it actually has a very clean
global structure that doesn't it sort of
doesn't have a lot of detail on top of
the main ideas you know it really so i
think that's what i'm picking for today
um and then in the next one i'll talk
about some algorithms that were based on
a different framework
okay so
um
moving back to math uh
so last time just to remind you where we
were we said that the key parameter that
defined how quickly you can solve a
linear system is the condition number
which is the ratio of biggest the
smallest eigenvalue and we gave an
iterative method whose iteration bound
was proportional to the square root of
it times log one over epsilon to get an
epsilon approximate solution
um and if you the nice thing about it
was just doing matrix vector multiplies
as its main time
comp the mean time per iteration so each
iteration took of m time where m is the
number of non-zeros and entries in the
matrix
so it wasn't n squared you know just it
was an m so because multiplying by
sparse matrix is actually much faster
than multiplying by a dense one
and the first question was is this
enough to solve laplacians in nearly
linear time and i said briefly at the
end no
uh before we get to the sort of real
reason why no let me just mention a
little technicality that we should deal
with which is just that i guess strictly
the way i define this the condition
number is infinity
uh because laplacians have a kernel
right we know that the all ones vector
uh is the cr is in the kernel of
laplacian so for a connected graph you
have a kernel that
is uh of dimension equal to the number
of connected components so throughout
the rest of everything i say all graphs
will be connected in which case you have
this one-dimensional kernel coming from
the old vector
and
that certainly is not a good running
time to take the square root of infinity
uh this is a really not big deal um the
point is we know where the kernel is and
if you look at and we don't even really
need to as long as we know it's a very
simple kernel it's the all one vector
morally just think we're working on the
orthogonal complement of the all one
vector everything we did yesterday is
just applying polynomials to matrices
so you don't even really need to know
where the kernel is as long as i feed
you a right hand side vector that
actually has a solvable linear system
you can essentially just think
everything we're doing is just working
on the complement of the all ones vector
and it doesn't present any real issues
uh so really you should think lambda 2
is the thing that's going to govern the
min eigenvalue
um now note that we already have a
result that's not super obvious which is
that we have a you can solve the policy
in linear systems very efficiently on
expanders
right and the reason for that is that
each iteration takes linear time and if
you look at what is an expander expander
is something where the ratio of its
biggest smallest eigenvalue is
a constant right so
we've now actually argued that if i were
to just try to style i'll remind you a
little bit about definitions of applause
on the next slide very briefly this is
just sort of
high-level culture but
note that for expanders the condition
number is constant and so the number of
iterations is just something like log
one over epsilon
um by the way a quick terminology thing
i'm going to say today uh if i ever say
nearly linear or put a tilde over
something it means i'm neglecting log
factors
and also i'll sometimes just write
polylog when it might be one log or two
or something just because i don't want
to get i'm not really
too concerned with how many there are
and i think it will cloud the picture so
um i'm gonna be a little imprecise with
some of these things today uh they
shouldn't hopefully it won't cause
confusion if it does just stop me
okay so
uh
this says that you can solve expanders
very quickly um
and
the real problem is that the opposite of
an expander a graph that has a very
small lambda 2 is going to immediately
break this right so if i give you lambda
2 very small if i give you a graph of
sparse cuts something's going to go
wrong and you know so i guess the
example thing that really exemplifies
this is pads where i said yesterday the
condition number is what is n squared
right the smallest eigenvalue is 1 over
n squared
and you know that means that we have n
iterations because it's the square root
of that and that's a really not good
algorithm for what we're going to do
any questions on that
okay so now
the first question is maybe
we can just improve our analysis of
something or construct better
polynomials because remember you know
the path is structured and
i don't know if i gave you a
well-structured instance maybe instead
of using chebyshev polynomials you
should do something else and pick a
polynomial that does something good and
you strongly can't
so um
i actually claim that no
straight iterative method of the form i
talked about yesterday has any hope of
solving that and it's for a very very
simple reason
the simple reason is just
uh if you look at what we're doing every
step we're multiplying by the matrix and
you know the laplacian is just the
identity plus the adjacency matrix and
so after k iterations we're looking at a
polynomial of degree k in the velocity
and you'll note that that only knows
about paths of length k right so just
let's talk adjacency matrix for a second
each time you multiply by a you get
another you get pads that are one longer
so if you look at a to the hundred you
only get pads of blamed 100
right and so in particular any
polynomial i ever hope to write down if
i give you a path of length n
uh it needs n iterations means you know
to look at polynomials of degree n just
to get anything from the left side of
the path to the right
so
so really there's just no hope
of making better polynomials because
you
have to somehow you know you're the
answer if i put
something one into the path of the other
is actually supported on the whole path
and so you really just need
to somewhere along the line write a
polynomial that can
you know touch paths of link then so you
just need degree and if no matter how
well you do
yeah
uh yeah so this was one example but in
particular anything with a diameter you
always need at least the diameter yes
um
so this means that we can't just hope to
abstractly fix all these problems
without talking about graphs of it
now you might notice that paths are not
very hard uh the reason they're not very
hard is they're very easy linear systems
and you can just do them by hand by
direction ethics and what we'll see
today is that sort of the i think the
motivating picture which doesn't it kind
of gets hidden in the
cleaner analyses and i think it's more
in the motivations film and tang had
then
somehow the more recent ones have
managed to get around it but i think
just a nice high level picture to keep
in mind is that pads are easy because
you can do them by hand expanders are
easy because they're very well
conditioned
and a variety of graph decomposition
things that have appeared in the last
couple decades will say that in one way
or another all graphs can be thought of
as being sort of a bunch of expanders
glued together in a tree and recurse
somehow you can partition graphs into
expanders and then collapse them in
partition and collapse and morally you
can think of all graphs as in some sense
being some combination of trees and
expanders and hopefully you can combine
those two
um i'll make out now it's just good to
keep that in mind cause it's gonna get
hidden in what i'm about to say but it's
a good design paradigm to have it in
mind for a lot of fast algorithms yeah
so if you're confused
so for an expander you show that
constant number of iterations are enough
though the diameter is logging oh sorry
but you need to get an error of one over
n squared or something to get an answer
so
the condition number is constant the
um the epsilon that you need to get a
good solution should be like poly one
over poly um and so
yeah that's a good point
next other questions
um and in fact you could get a constant
of error that you know with a very low
power um it just might be
poppier okay
so
um and just kind of more generally this
maybe is this jumping off point for some
of this recent line of work is that it's
not just that lines are bad
and expanders are good it's that there's
really a very strong connection between
the conditioning of these laplacians and
the cut structure right lucas talks
didn't just show you have triggers
inequality that says cuts are directly
boundable in terms of the
condition number of these things and
vice versa but it's actually more than
that it's that the structure of the
eigenvalues how many big ones how many
small ones how big they are is very
strongly related to all of the cuts in
the graph somehow each cut in the graph
presents one bad eigenvalue or something
like that
and once you and when you and in order
to sort of understand the linear
algebraic structure you have to
understand where the sparse cuts are in
a graph and that's kind of the main
roadblock that these methods have to get
around
um okay so now we're now stuck with i
guess an assertion that there's
something good that can happen and then
a promise that nothing i told you last
time doesn't
so what i want to talk about now is just
a general method my last general method
before i get to laplacian which is
preconditioning that's going to be how
you can hope to
solve the line given or solve things
where you know they have bad condition
number and you know just broadly the
question is what do you do to solve
things where kappa is big where it's
badly conditioned it's not totally
hopeless you know here i wrote down a
linear system with kappa as a million
that one iterative method will in fact
take a very long time on but um
especially because if you want to solve
a symmetric linear system you can square
it but the good news is that um
i actually can look at this i can kind
of eyeball it and say the reason it's
badly conditioned is just because this
diagonal is really badly behaved if i
just do d first times it i can now look
at it and get something that's actually
really well conditioned
so morally if i understand why something
is badly conditioned i can hope to fix
it
and so you'd think that here
uh
modulus and caveats i'll tell you on the
next slide the fact that i was able to
look at this eyeball and do a simple
transformation to make it well
conditioned said that now instead of
just solving with something with a i'll
just solve something with d inverse a
now i've got a nice well conditioned
system
so more generally
um
preconditioning just says i want to
solve a poorly conditioned system and
suppose i know a positive definite
matrix m
that's very similar algebraically so uh
something where m inverse a is close to
the identity in some appropriate sense
but where i'm able to one way or another
easily
invert this approximate matrix so i have
a simpler matrix on the previous one it
was a diagonal matrix that has some
algebraic similarity to the one that i
want to solve but it is nice it's one
that i can invert by a simpler method um
and then you can just consent solving
inverse a
equals m inverse b that might be right
this time and the
that's actually
maybe a major win like and here morally
we're going to say we understand graphs
by where their cuts are and this is
going to let us understand how to kind
of
make something that gets rid of the bad
eigenvalues
so
okay there's a couple complications that
i'm going to just very quickly mention
i'm not going to and by the way today is
going to be sketchier than last lecture
in the sense that i'm going to start as
the lecture wears on more and more
aggressively emitting details this one's
a mild omission but when we get to the
solvers they really are quite
complicated uh the spielman tang one i
think is something like 150 pages if you
concatenate the contents the one i'm
talking about today if you put the
numerical analysis in i think still is
in the 60 to 70 range
so
i'm going to start a bit of detail so
i'm going to hope to convey the picture
so okay main questions one is where do
we get this pre-conditioner uh the other
is that
you know you don't really want to
compute down versus a because that's
complicated right you know again we
don't want to do full inversions and the
third one is that i told you everything
for symmetric matrices and i've made
probably a not symmetric matrix
so the short answers are where do we get
m is
i have no idea um so in general it's a
hard question and it's a
problem-specific question
and this has no general answer you
should think of this as saying a
preconditioner is when you understand
the structure of your problem you can
hope to use it
so there's not if this is a non-trivial
question and one that will instantiate
for specific classes
uh the expensive to compute m inverse a
same thing we did yesterday don't
compute them in verse a we're only doing
matrix vector multiplies so you have to
be able to multiply by an inverse
and a which amounts to solving linear
systems not inverting matrices
and the not symmetric one it's really
not a huge deal and let me tell you
roughly why it's not a huge deal
roughly why it's not a huge deal is that
it's not a symmetric matrix but it's
pretty close and the reason is that you
can define a symmetric matrix
um
so
the idea is that if i take m to the
negative one if i assume m is psd i can
take a square root i can make n to the
negative half and then note that by
similarity m to the negative 1a and m to
the negative a half a m to the negative
half have the same eigenvalues and if i
multiply a string of these if i apply a
polynomial to m inverse a or
the other one into the negative a half a
m to the negative a half
they're pretty much the same the same
stuff happens in the middle and it's
just a conjugation on the beginning and
end and so morally everything we did
yesterday should work fine under the
appropriate change of variables
and a little more precisely if you look
at
whatever polynomial we did last time
applied to m inverse a times m inverse b
um and just
if you apply the same polynomial and the
analysis we did
gives
the same kind of bound it gives a bound
with uk applied to lambda i
um on the a
and the only crucial thing to note is
that actually when you write it out we
are using that we're using the a norm
here so when you write things out you'll
see that the fact that i can kind of
start playing around with uh m's and a's
and commuting them in various ways when
you write this out you'll see that it
gives a reasonable boundary the a norm
not a reasonable bound in the l2 norm
and this is one more reason why the a
norm is the right thing to work with
okay so short version was don't worry
about it not a huge deal rewrite the
analysis from yesterday essentially
verbatim
and everything goes through
and really it's because m inverse a is
only barely not symmetric we know it has
nice eigenvalues we know it's related to
a symmetric matrix and so we're in good
shape okay so now
i have difficulty with this because
for example
i know that
if it is not symmetric
the prone vector
could be exponentially off
yes and then the convergence
will be a huge problem right so the
point here is that we actually
don't have that so you know you should
think that what we're really doing is
running the whole algorithm on m to the
negative a half a m to the negative a
half which is symmetric
um
and
then
the eigenvalues of m is the negative
symmetric
asymmetric
yeah so out right so everything yeah a
is symmetric
um and it will depend on the eigenvalues
of this you know this uh
matrix here which is
sorry i should have been working this is
under the assumptions from before plus
it's unders a is symmetric and pd
okay thanks
so now where do preconditioners come
from um and again it's really artworth
and science because it is problem
specific we're trying to outperform
general linear system solving and
um the basis for the algorithms that
will have to wrap the classes is going
to be to really understand the structure
and get a class of reconditioners
so just i want to give you a very quick
reminder somebody asked me just to throw
in in case you missed previous talks
what is laplacian i'm going to do this
at lightning pace because the last
couple days have been about them but
just to remind and fix notation and
remind you i give you a graph uh it will
be a weighted graph
um laplacian matrix is d minus a so d is
the diagonal matrix of weighted degrees
a is the weighted adjacency matrix
l is the amino acid so that was my
definition looks like this right so
diagonal entries are the weighted degree
you have negative on the off
non-diagonal if you have negative
whatever the degree the weight of the
edges
um and
we'll see over and over that it's often
better to think about this as the
corresponding quadratic form like really
for most things that one will do the
more natural object to look at is x
transpose l x
and in that case it's the sum over all
the edges of the weight of the edge
times x i minus x j quantity squared
and that's the one that we'll work with
okay so this is what we're going to
solve today we're solving systems lx
equals b this is these are l's um
okay i think i'm gonna and so
if there's questions about this later
just let me know but this is fixed
notation what we're working with in
particular note we are not using the
normalized laplacian we're using the
regular one
so
uh the eigenvalues are between zero and
something that's like theta of d not
theta of one we're not scaling
everything down
okay so
let's talk about preconditioners and
linear systems our goal is to solve lx
equals v
and the first question is why should we
hope for this to be easier than solving
all linear systems
we're not going to solve all linear
systems in linear time
that would be a better talk
and so one good reason why laplacian's
nice is that there what's called weakly
diagonally dominant which means that in
every row if you take the diagonal entry
it so diagonally weekly diagonally
dominant means that it's greater than or
equal to the sum of all other entries in
the realm so flipping back to the side
here it's actually exactly equal right
like the four here is exactly equal to
the sum of those other three numbers
essentially by definition
um here the weak and just to instantiate
the terms weekly is that it's uh greater
than or equal to not a strict inequality
and for graphs it's actually a strict
equality it's like the least diagonally
dominant weekly that i've done in the
system
um
and why is that helpful the reason it's
helpful is that it actually tells us
where the null space is so in particular
we know exactly what the kernel of our
matrix is and a general principle that i
think is good to keep in mind when
trying to pre-condition stuff is what
we're trying to do is crudely
approximate the inverse of a matrix
multiplicatively
in particular 1 over 0 is a very bad
multiplicative approximation and so if
you want to
excuse me any hope of solving a linear
system or preconditioning linear system
you really strongly better know where
the null space is and you should do that
like certainly checking if your answer
is infinity should be
no uh shouldn't be harder than
solving a whole linear system
and so for them and what's nice about
weak diagonal dominance is that you can
actually look at it and write down
the same the proof that says that
there's no other kernel of your matrix
to immediately look at it eyeball it you
know the crew and in particular we also
know that you can by all the cut stuff
we've talked about eyeball and not only
where the kernel is but where the almost
kernel is where the bad eigenvalues are
and that's related to class
um i should mention that everything we
talked about today can be extended to
solve any weakly diagonally dominant
system not just laplacians and it's
really a straight black box reduction
um negative off diagonals
are um
basically graphs with self loops so if i
just if i keep my non-diagonal entries
negative the only difference between
laplacians and weak diagonal dominants
is
that here we have exact equality to you
know the row exactly summed up that i
had no entry and it could set up to less
than or equal that actually just makes
the problem easier can sort of think
self loops
and
uh it's a pretty easy reduction the
slightly harder one is if i allow myself
to put
positive entries in the non-diagonal
entries
so if i instead of making negatives on
the non-diagonals make arbitrary numbers
whose absolute values sum up to
something less than diagonal that
there's also a reduction
but it's not completely trivial involves
making two copies of the graph and uh so
it's a simple black box reduction to
write down but it requires some
creativity i think it goes back to
grandfather um
is that right okay
is it just mchale's talk i don't know
how did the kill do the possibility no
he said i mean that's the same as the uh
when he took two graphs and put them
together right oh the two lifts
what it means i don't think that's
exactly the same what was it called uh
where you take two were you two copies
of a graph and then you start switching
the edges yeah i don't think that's
exactly the same but i think it's it's
identical to that
yeah double cover right is it okay it's
just a double coverage organically for
that right it's so it's it's got the
right part just be a little careful
because there's no
um
there's no graph if you put the positive
entry does not melt into anything but
yeah okay so gary the the reduction
looks like is a is the sparsity pattern
of a double cover with these real good
signs so
okay so
good now it's going to move to the core
of this which is how to use sparsifiers
to pre-condition now gary you're right
uh you're right about the structure
uh
yeah so what do you think the
possibility of going to
positive positive seminars
to all psds so all psd is all matrices
because because um you can solve the ax
equals b you can just multiply by a
transpose on both sides
and reduce all matrices to psd matrices
um and then so that would
um i think you need more ideas right
like i think that there
is a strong difference between the two i
mean that would
once what's this strong difference like
what i mean in particular you can't even
so i think my guess the kernel answer is
a pretty good one which is that one
major difference with these matrices
from general matrices
is i can guess whether the matrix is
invertible very easily i can just check
if the graph is connected
and for a general
psd matrix i don't know how to do that i
would say that if you could give me a
fast algorithm for just verifying
whether
a matrix was invertible
or very close to an end then make it a
little bit robust so make it then you'd
probably end up with a faster algorithm
but i don't know how to do that for a
general matrix
so the diagonal dominance is that's
really i think where the wind is so you
can check where the kernel is very
efficiently and understand where the
eigen values are
but then if you have a positive definite
matrix then it's
so you really don't just need the
promise you need to know why because i
guess my assertion that it's you need to
be able to eyeball it and know
where the
big and small eigenvalues are
so here we know where the cuts are if i
promise it's positive definite you
really don't know how to exploit that i
give you a really good reason for it
then you can hope to design a
precondition
so
okay so here's the jumping off point for
where combinatorics will come in um
nicole showed that any graph can be
specified so he showed that there exists
a graph h for any graph g with n poly
log n edges so that you can
approximate the graph with psd matrices
and he actually showed of n but i'm
going to not talk about those because
they're not fast enough for over my use
so
um i'm going to backtrack to the
effective resistance sampling and then
polylogging results because we're
shooting for nearly linear time
algorithms so the other
sparse fire constructions take too long
for what we're gonna try to use them for
um and yeah i'd rather just my notation
here that's less than or equal to it's
gonna be the same thing that people have
used before this talk which is uh psd
at you know every right a little
uh
slightly curved less than or equal to it
just means that if i subtract them i get
something pst
yeah
so the linear time algorithm only
applies to graphical velocities right i
mean it's not the generally diagonal
dominant things
um right so the idea is we're going to
solve graph laplacians and have a
reduction to that case
so
like the
the
previous couple slides ago the
assertions that they gave you a black
box algorithm for laplacians and general
diagonal dominant matrices can
solve a problem with twice that size and
uh and solve it so it's a reduction but
now i'm not going to work with that
general ones i'll just reduce two just
that make sense
so i made a black box reduction and i'm
just going to solve the thing i reduced
to i'm just going to solve the bossians
today and then assert that there's a
reduction from general to this case it's
just a lifting that nickel talked about
all you do is you take your original
thing and you view it as a lifting
right you you put it's a two n by two in
matrix you put
negative the right hand side and
positive right hand side on the right
and put the positive ones in one block
and the negative one is together it's
not
too low
okay so this is our point and now what's
nice about this is that
this i claim implies that the sparsifier
is a good preconditioner for the
original graph
and why is that so what exactly does
this psd thing do it says if i were to
multiply both sides by l h to the
negative a half
and again a couple of morphologies i'm
going to write negative ones and
negative a halfs instead of pseudo
inverses today because i'm completely
ignoring the all one vector
none of these matrices have inverses
because they have kernels but just think
everything i do is on the complement of
the all one vector and it makes my
notation less messy
okay so all of the eigenvalues of this
so the l h negative the half l g l h
negative half i just multiply that whole
thing through one left and right i get
that all the eigenvalues are between one
minus epsilon and one plus epsilon
and so in particular this is really good
news because it says that if i use the
sparsifier as a preconditioner
i get a relative i get a condition
number that's one plus or minus epsilon
and so
if i were able to handle the sparsifier
then i'd be able to handle the original
graph
so
this does almost tell us something it
almost tells us that you can use
laplacian linear systems for all graphs
as if they're sparse
and all you do is multiply the number of
iterations by a log factor so that's
already a non-trivial assertion right it
says you can solve
dense graphs
in a time you know using a logarithmic
number of iterations of
a sparse graph so you've already saved a
factor of almost n
yeah so is there a way
this is removing
sparse pets or something
so this one is more um you're
understanding the sparse cuts by solving
the original graph so the idea is that
the spark it's more that the sparse cuts
in h and g are basically the same
because it's um the promise that a
sparsifier gives you is that they have
the same cut structure
and so the way you're sort of removing
the sparse cuts here is very aggressive
you're doing it by
exactly expanding everything about the
sparsifier and it has the same cuts as
the original
um
does that make sense yes
okay so now all we've done is multiply
the iteration by small factor of course
you know we need to find it efficiently
so you you started with a matrix that
has mostly zeros and minus ones and the
lh could have um bigger numbers right is
that a problem uh they're not going to
be that much bigger so if you start with
an unleaded graph they'll still be poly
polynomials
and so it's not like uh you'll lose some
logs
um so you know when you do these
sparsifier constructions you're never
going to make the size of the numbers
grow up i grew up by more than a
polynomial factor so it's not going to
ever really change anything inside the
numbers you can probably make the number
of logs i just heading to somewhere
between zero and one but it's not it
it's the sparse fires don't blow up the
numbers too much is the point but yeah
you're right it is a real concern um but
now that
like it's the point is just the
sparsifiers don't you don't ever need to
use numbers that are much bigger than
the ones when you're in the graph
um
i also designed age efficiently i think
mchill briefly talked about the older
ones i did it um
not you but like the nice one that i
kind of wanted to talk about is the
effective resistance sampling algorithm
and that's what's going to motivate
what's in this
construct the constructions they do
today the important thing about
effective resistance sampling is that
the way you compute the effective
resistance is by solving a linear system
and so it's really not great to have a
linear system solver as a prerequisite
solver
so
we can't quite use it and that's our
like well like the way that one does
affect the the cleanest fortification
algorithm i know of is you compute
effective resistances by solving a
linear system
and you can't use that as to solve your
systems um yes
oh so then the the convention is to say
that
the preconditioner
like
a is i want that you say that lh is the
preconditioner and you use the ability
to solve linear systems in it
so i believe that the way so the way you
if i have a and b and a you a and b are
similar to each other then you have to
solve that inverse b type
uh
but you say that a preconditions b
and not that a insert and so the way the
way you use it is not actually compute
the inverse
ability because otherwise right it might
be something
right so the idea is that if i can solve
linear systems for lh
then i can use that
um
then we know
that this has good eigenvalues so l is
so
if i were to look at instead of solving
linear systems so we know that
um i can use it as a pre-condition for
solving things with the original graph i
can and then what i need to be able to
do is in each iteration i need to be
able to
uh solve your systems in lh
i need to multiply by the original graph
i need to because i need to be able to
compute the right-hand side
um
sorry each equation still involves
multiplication by l g right it does yeah
but then then ld may not be spot so
um so you can't ever hope to do better
than the number of edges in the original
graph because you're going to be able to
compute residuals so i guess i should
have been a little more careful what i
said here that statement seems to say
you know you can slope it as if it's box
but um so you can solve it as you can
solve it as if it's sparse in the sense
that if i
it so this degenerates a bit in the case
for the number of iterations where it's
in your linear algorithm imagine that
linear system solving was was you know
required more than a constant or long
number of iterations
then
um
somehow i guess you're right i should
have been a little more careful here it
says that you've reduced solving to
multiplication by the original matrix
and solving a simpler matrix um so
okay so
there is a um
so the earlier papers film and ten paper
constructed a sparse tie are not using
effective resistances but more by hand i
think you'll talk a bit about that but
um instead we're going to do something
that for our applications is vastly
better um and we're going to kind of
dodge the problem entirely
um and for that let me tell you what
we'll do we're going to construct much
larger matrices so you know i said
sparsifiers are useful here but i guess
i if you try to underline what i said it
doesn't really hold water because the
sparse bar gets numbered edges n log n
over epsilon squared but
um you know you still have to solve a
linear system in something or then log
into reps restaurant squared edges if i
started with a sparse graph in the first
place i haven't gotten anywhere for a
living or solved
now what we're going to do here is we're
going to say
what's nice about these iterative
methods is they actually work pretty
well with pretty bad approximations if i
gave you a much cruder i only need one
plus or minus epsilon i could get away
with log n and then i just multi i just
use that log n times and good things
happen so the question we're going to
ask is what if i want to do a much
weaker approximation
can i instead i use a much simpler graph
so instead of treating for n log n over
epsilon squared i'm true for something
very small and then hope that i can
again wrap that in an iterative method
to make up for it
and what we'll show is that actually you
can do this
this is a component of
something like this is in the spielman
tang one and in the cooperative one and
essentially every preconditioned
system that will show up i'm going to do
the kuzmil pen construction which makes
a much cleaner caller
and so what we're going to show is that
you can get a graph with n minus one
plus m over k edges so that the
condition number is
o tilde k
so okay like k polynomial k
um and this they call in the paper
incremental versus time now
so the way to think about this is think
about this i have to have a spanning
tree like if i have a disconnected graph
i'm really in trouble and this says that
i take a standing tree plus a very small
number of edges m over
and whatever i want okay to be and then
i lose a k in my approximation
so
why is this sometimes better well um the
main point is if i give you what's m is
the original number of things
so that
yeah i guess i was going to apologize
for m being not n later
and deal with it but one of the problems
of course is if your graph is dense this
may be bad that was for both points down
but um yeah so i think
uh if the end is the future sparse graph
this is a big win if the m is dense you
have to deal with it
um and why this is sometimes better is
imagine m is imagine you're starting
with a fairly sparse graph then this
could be very small think of it as could
be square root of n
yeah um and now the real point here for
that is that for a lot of algorithms in
particular linear system solvers
morally i give you a tree plus k edges
if the solving problems on it is
something linear time and then a graph
that's really of size of k
so if i were and i'll say this in more
depth in a bit but you know morally if i
have a path i can sort of collapse the
path to an edge
and
the real core of the problem is is
kind of encapsulated by the graph i get
when i take all these long paths and
collapse them so if i give you a tree
plus a small number of edges you can
reduce the problem to a graph to
to and linear time to something that
really is like a graph whose number of
vertices and edges depends more on the
number of the edges you've added to the
spanning tree not the number of edges
not the whole graph so this is going to
operate like something that's of size m
over k give or take
and then we're going to hope so what we
can hope to do is for example
you know imagine thinking of k is root n
and n is like m you could hope to reduce
the problem to get a condition number of
root n with one plus with something
that's one plus root n
and n minus one plus root n edges and
then collapse that to a size root n
problem
and hope that something good happens so
that's the high level picture you can
boost it to much smaller problems
um i'll skip the details but give me two
points so i'm going to do is i'm going
to start with the main main points then
i'm going to start iteratively refining
them so the super high level structure
is the following graph approximations
give pre-conditioners so we can use
combinatorics if i give you a graph with
a tree plus a c edges i can solve linear
systems in that object in o then time to
sort of collapse the paths
plus linear systems on graphs of size of
c
um
i can then use incremental sparsifiers
to get preconditioners of the form tree
plus c edges
so and then
we'll talk about how to do that in a
little bit um and then it's going to be
using low stretch standing trees plus
resistance sampling
and then
that is to use this inside a recursively
preconditioned solver so i'm not going
to do the root and i just said before
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
approximate a graph with a graph that's
like polylog and small let's you know a
couple log n smaller and then
i'm going to shrink it by log n log n
times so think that i'm just have like n
n over log in and over log squared n and
over log q again
with different constants in what i just
added and i'll have log n levels of log
of recursive preconditioning and
put that inside so then i'll use each
level to pre-condition the one before it
okay that's the super high level
structure and now let me fill in what a
little more about each of those pieces
so again the really high level point is
that i can reduce a graph to a much
smaller graph
at the expense of having to solve more
linear systems
and so what i'll do is i'll the logins
are because i if i get a root i'd have
to solve too many linear systems and so
this is just to make the references work
and what we'll do is precondition graph
by simpler graph by simpler graph by
simpler graph by simpler graph
and then use our iterative methods to
buy our way out of the fact that we've
simplified our graph
so let me start with how do you simplify
really star systems
um so my assertion of tree plus the
edges can
you know is basically a graphic size c
plus some linear time stuff i'm going to
kind of draw a picture morally it's just
that leaves and pads are easy
um i'm running a little slow so i'm
gonna make my picture a little bit of a
crude picture but roughly the idea is if
i told you to solve in your system
on i don't know something plus some plus
a tree hanging off of it so i think this
is anything arbitrary
and then i have a tree or a path hanging
off of it then you can
you basically can do back substitution
to collapse the leaves up to the base so
you can solve it by a direct solver
more generally if i were to make these
cycles if i give you
if i give you just any steady internal
path any sequence of edges that are all
degree two or one then you can do what's
called partial trotsky factorization you
can basically in linear time figure out
how to what will happen on the path and
collapse it to a single edge
so just think you can do this by direct
solvers it's a pretty reasonable
exercise
um
you know it's just that solving things
on lines is super easy you can do it by
hand and it's just back substitution so
you can kind of collapse the paths down
to edges
and nearly limited time
is that reasonable to people i'm happy
to write this out if people want me to
um
but
maybe i shouldn't because i think the
rest of it is the more exciting part but
the point is just that paths are easy
and the only way the rest of the graph
interacts with the path is through sort
of what comes in and what comes out and
so you can collapse the path after that
and and and
and the link is at the cost of one
linear time computation
okay so
this is what they call paper greedy
elimination and this is what lets us say
that actually if you get a tree plus a
small number of edges you can make the
number of vertices shrink down something
that's like the number of additional
edges you've added i'm saying a small
comment that
could explain why this works the average
degree in the
vertices in a tree is a little less than
two therefore you must have either long
path or many loops
yes um
right sometimes that's oh i guess i
should have said
oh i should have said two comments right
they've said two comments one is that
you can collapse pads and the other like
that i didn't say out loud but you
should have was there are a lot of pads
you know and
uh that actually is exactly the proof
which is that if you look at the average
degree
um if i give you a tree plus a small
number of edges you have to have a lot
of degree one or two vertices
and consider
the factor of
two so this is good news
um and now let me give you the high
level of pre-conditioning structure
you're gonna make a chain of graphs
uh there's gonna be two kinds sort of
a's and b's i think one of them is
sparsifying the other is this collapsing
operation so i'll have a chain of graphs
and they'll have the following
properties uh the i i'll just say
notation wise ni and mi are the number
of edges and vertices vertices and edges
of the ai
ai plus one comes from bi by doing this
greedy elimination so bi is going to be
something that's tree plus small number
of edges and a i plus one is going to be
the thing you get by collapsing pads and
um and leaves
and then uh the bis are going to be a
sparsification thing using the
incremental sparse definers i'll
describe shortly so the bis are good
approximations of the ais
with some parameter kafka that we hope
to make small
so you know the setup is you start with
your whole graph you're then going to
get an incremental sparsify we're going
to try to get rid of almost all the
edges get down to 3 plus small number of
edges
then you're going to take the tree plus
small number of edges and collapse it to
a graph of many fewer vertices but but a
fairly dense one then you're going to
sparsify it and you're going to collapse
then you're going as far as to find your
complex
and that's our sequence
um and what you're going to want to have
happen is that stuff has to fall off
fast enough that this doesn't
well that this actually works quickly
and so what you're going to want
um is that the number of edges shrinks
fairly quickly between different days so
that the uh the process of sparsifying
and clapping does something useful and
what you're going to want is that the
ratio of the number of edges
in particular so we're going to talk
about edges more than vertices here you
want the number of edges is going to
fall off
at least at a root kappa rate where
kappa is this parameter
um you know kappa is a function of n is
the parameter that we want to make small
so you want to say that the sizes shrink
very quickly
and the other and my assertion is if i
give you this
we're actually going to be in really
good shape you can get an algorithm that
will solve laplacians up to an epsilon
error in the a norm in time that is like
the starting point uh number you know
the sorry the size of the original graph
the size of the final graph cubed
so let me tell you where that was so the
m sub d is the size of the final graph
this is just do gaussian elimination at
the end so after you do all this
recursive pre-conditioning stuff you
have to solve your base case
so you pay for that with the
n cubed and you just make that small um
and then you have the square root of
this condition number
uh
yeah
sorry so the mi is that mi isn't the
number of edges in the original
graph or is that some is that the c from
before
so m i is the number that is in the ice
graph and think a1 is your original
graph
so m1 is the size of your starting graph
and md is the size of your last graph
and you're going to hope we're hoping
for something linear in the size of the
original graph think that md is like log
something or not really but think it's
very small it's going to be
small enough that this doesn't kill your
running time so you solve the last one
by hand
so the first step is really taking your
original graph and shrinking it right
shrinking all the time right
right so this is a sequence of graphs
that interpolates between your graph and
a really simple graph sort of little by
little
so does copper have anything to do with
the condition number here is just a new
function um well so the it's going to be
so kappa will be the condition number of
using beta as a preconditioner for alpha
for b is a prediction for a
because here it's just a function
um here well the whole so here it is a
condition yes of how to solve the
recursive preconditioning system it will
be the condition number of the systems
you'll solve
um and the hope is that you can get it
to be small enough that you don't pay
for it a lot
um so in the next couple bullet points
i'm going to tell you how that what you
do with this chain but yeah it's going
to be the condition numbers that show up
um and this is the proposed running time
you should think kappa is something
involving condition numbers and
iteration time
m1 is the starting point and v is the
base case and the logarithm loading
epsilon is the log one for example
so the basic idea of how you use this
conditioner this is chained to do
everything with those volumes the idea
is that i can solve it
again but i'm going to continue with the
final expression because even if you
ignore the mdq which could only make
your life a little worse that's the
exact expression that you had when you
wrote this establishment expression
um right so
the reply to the first graph uh so the
hope the root cap at n
is not the condition number of the first
um
so it's remember kappa of n is a
function it's not sorry it's not the
condition number of the laplacian
it's the kappa of n that appears in my
approximation sequence so
then i'm coming back from the previous
question so how should you interpret
this function
and how what does this have to do with
conditioning
um so okay so what is something that i
think
and it's going to be uh that we're going
to do the incremental sparsification
construction to get
this is going to be graph and
incremental sparsifiers and we're going
to do that so that it's how well b
approximates a so that when i
recursively precondition with it
um it's the condition number of the
precondition system
and so we're going to make this
polynomial
it means that um in your approximation
before when you were when you were
specifying you want uh
that kind of uh right and so um
is this is it the case that for this to
happen you must start with a sparse
enough crap
so
that's i'll get there um hopefully uh
yes
as stated yes we need one more idea
which is to make that not think
morally yes and one of the main
innovations in the paper i'm describing
was to not have that be a problem
so
i haven't yet so i'm gonna fill the
details in iterations for now that is a
legitimate worry
um like how we get this chain i have not
yet told you
um i just want to say that if i give you
this chain something good happens
um and the idea is
why how do you use the existence of the
sequence of graphs to solve everything
the idea is that i can solve a system
for bi by solving a system for ai using
this elimination argument right the b's
are these all are these various sparse
graphs
and i can solve a system for a i by
solving this number of linear systems
from b i
right so the point was this condition
number is how well b approximates a so
how many you know how many
pre-conditioned iterations i need to
solve to use b of b to solve a and so
what i'm hoping to do is reduce solving
a linear system of a to solving root cap
of the animal in your system to b
where b is hopefully smaller
so those are the two assertions i've
already given you and this almost gives
the right returns so the idea is that
now what's going to happen
is that each step is going to reduce a
system with m non-zeros am i
to a system with square root of kappa n
i
so um so the number of linear systems
that we solve
ignore the log one with rexon for a
second and not for any legitimate reason
um just ignore it for a second
the root cap at n we're going to reduce
each step
um so we're going to log on to epsilon
the number of iterations i need is root
kappa n
so i have to solve root kappa and linear
systems in these smaller objects so the
smaller objects are size m over root cap
a
so i've reduced solving something of
size m to solving things of sine m over
root kappa n
copied you know that many copies of m
over with m over root kappa and entries
and that is the gives the recurrence we
promised um
so that actually right like the number
so the idea is the number of non-zero
values of b becomes the size of a
and now i've actually gotten something
that expands out to the recurrence of
given
so that almost is good enough right so
again the idea is that i've got these
graphs have fallen off in size very
quickly but i have to do a bunch of them
i do solve in one system to solving
polylog systems that are of size a lot
smaller
and
that gives us our occurrence the reason
i've lied to you is this loud one over
epsilon which is um i don't want to talk
about it right now i'm running a little
slow but roughly the point was is that
if you had to pay the log one over
epsilon at every stage in this process
we're trying to get you know in order
for this argument to make sense we're
trying to get epsilon to be one over
poly n
and then you'd get
um you'd multiply this by like log n to
the log n power which would be a very
bad linear system solver
um and the idea is that this is where my
yesterday promised that we need to use
chebyshev or the fixed polynomial
instead of conjugate gradient which is
adaptive it was really for this which is
going to say that actually what we can
do is essentially only take a log one
over epsilon on the outside of the whole
process because we have a fixed
polynomial in the a's and everything is
linear
and i'll let me not draw in the numerics
there and i'll come back to it offline
with people's questions but that was
where we're using it it was that you
don't want to have to pay the
amplification for the error at every
step of this recursive preconditioning
or else you get a very bad solid time
okay so this is the setup the setup is
the graduate very quickly and so if we
can prove this we're in really good
shape
so now let's see if we can prove it and
the idea is we want to construct these
incremental specifiers
and
we can try to use effective resistance
sampling which operary doesn't really
work there's two real problems
so the first is we can't compute the
effective resistances and the second is
it doesn't give the right answer
um so
the reason doesn't give the right answer
is exactly the question that you're
asking a few minutes ago which is that
graphs don't have to be sparse right and
so if m is big then m over k is
you know possibly much bigger than n and
this didn't help us at all
so the idea is to deal with the first
issue is that we're going to not use the
resistances we're just going to use a
bound on them so nikhil showed in his
talk that if i just give you if i sample
things more than i'm supposed to it's
just as good if i get some lower bound
on the effective resistances that's fine
i just might i might be doing overkill i
might be taking more edges than i need
but i'm not
you know breaking anything
so we're just going to have to bound
them up upper bound from the effective
resistances um
right it'll just result in over sampling
and taking too many things
um and
uh we have to just make sure we can do
that in a way that doesn't cause too
many edges
um and then the idea here is what we're
going to do is use a scanning tree to
bound the effective resistances so let
me talk about that and i'll come back to
the too many edges
so
the idea with over sampling you know
here this is just i think that he'll
actually expanded this out but the
comment i just made what it really said
was that so again we're going to use
effective resistances which are one over
the weights of the edges
um the heel showed that if i
sample with probability proportional to
the taus
then i get a decent i get a decent
approximation
um and the setup was that uh each sample
we will take independently samples of
each edge with probability tau over the
total
um and the number of samples
um
you know is what dictates how many how
sparse a graph we get that's dictated by
that by t
and it will work exactly as long if we
use lower bounds but we have to make
sure that t isn't too big if we're too
crude in our lower in our upper bounds
then we'll just we couldn't you know i
could just make them all one um you know
we'll get too many edges so that's kind
of our main goal
and the idea uh which i
stole some slides from richard peng
is that we're going to bound the
effective resistances with a spanning
tree
instead of computing them exactly so we
don't want to solve a hole in your
system we're just going to get a crude
enough approximation to do things well
and the rayleigh monotone monotonicity
law it's a effective resistance
assertion which just says that if i take
edges out of the graph if i cut wires i
only make the effective resistance
bigger
right like if i take away options i
can't make the optimization problem have
a better answer
and so we're going to do and this seems
like it's too aggressive it really does
is we're going to take this whole
complicated graph we're just going to
pick a spanning tree
um and we're going to bound the effect
use that to bound the effect we're going
to erase all the edges but a tree and
use the tree about then on a tree it's
super easy to compute effective
resistances it's just add up the stuff
on half
and we're going to use that to bound
everything
um so
right because if i give you a path it's
just you add up the resistances
so now um
what does this tell us it tells us the
sample probability we're using for edges
is just the weight of the original edge
uh times the effective resistance of
this long path that i've replaced it
with you know morally i'm taking an edge
and i'm
i'm when i erase an edge i'm replacing
it with this whole path in the tree and
we'll define the stretch to be the ratio
of the original length to the length of
the path that i'm trying to replace it
with and that's the probability that
shows up in the effective resistances so
i'm starting to more aggressively sketch
because i'm running out of time but i'm
happy so but let me kind of i want to
get to the main points um so okay that's
the stretch the stretch is how big the
ratio is between the edge and the path
we're routing it along
um and after area that could be very big
if i give you a cycle then every edge i
stretch in
the trick
ignoring that for a second the trick is
that we're going to use the effective
resistances on a tree but try to choose
our tree so that this isn't too bad
um and the main combinatorial point here
is going to be that not all trees are
created equal so the total number of
edges that we're going to end up
sampling um if we think about the
probabilities that we computed before is
going to be proportional to the total
stretch right i just get proportionally
sampled sample proportional to their
stretch so the total number of edges is
proportional to the sum of all of the
stretches
and not all trees are equal
so if i give you a grid for example this
is a bad spanning tree so this tree has
total stretch and to the 1.5
and why is that is that if i take an
edge here i the stretch of this edge is
this whole path
um and so
those are rooted
that's bad this is good this is stretch
on log n
and
the main theorem we're going to use is
a theorem that says actually every graph
has a very good spanning tree
so the theorem is that given any graph i
can find a graph
whose spanning tree has total stretch
and log
so what does that mean
that and i can find it very quickly i
can find it nearly linear time so what
that means is that it says if i pick if
i look at the average for each edge of
the graph
you know morally an edge could be
stretched as much as n
and
in a cycle one of them has to be
uh this says that actually i have to get
some edges stretched a lot but i can
find a tree so the average stretch of an
edge is just log
which is very strong
feeling and it's um
if i have time at the end of my next
talk i'll sketch the construction it's a
very nice ball growing construction plus
some work
okay so
that is now going to say that we have
this nice this is where the combinator
come in is that this says that this
graph
actually gives us a good understanding
of the combinatorics
because it lets us get a graph where now
all these stretchers are only
um only logarithm owned by the here that
tilde is high in log logs after
yeah um and it's uh this says we can now
get a graph where
uh sort of the tree is very well
capturing the length of the paths
so
um now again we're back to this too many
edges issue the total stretch is m log n
that's still
not any plus a small number but
um the idea here is that we're being too
precise
so to fix this we're going to notice
that we can tolerate a condition number
of k right k was the
you know the number in that we wanted to
get m n minus 1 plus m over k and we
wanted a condition number of k for this
and we're shooting you know we're doing
the effective resistance thing which had
one plus or minus epsilon so we're just
being way too aggressive in our goal
so here what we're gonna do
is we're not gonna shoot for one plus or
minus epsilon we're gonna shoot for
something worse and the way we're gonna
do that is we're gonna scale the tree up
by k and this was a beautiful idea in
this paper so what it said was um why
we're going to start with the tree and
we're going to try to add edges to it
the tree is smaller than the graph and
so we can just keep it but then we're
going to get stuck with this total
stretch of that log n what we're going
to do is you know we're already going to
try to lose a factor okay so don't keep
the tree keep k times the tree which is
much bigger and that already now is
covering a lot of the out a lot of the
graph like it's really a much bigger
object than we started with and this is
going to let the effective resistances
go be much better because now the tree
is k times larger so now we'll have the
same non-tree edges but every
um
but now
i claim that the effective resistances
are going to fall off by like a factor
of k
right and so the idea is that first note
that i just scaled up a sub graph by a
factor of k my new graph is within you
know it's bounded below because it's a
sub graph and bounded above because i've
scaled it by a factor of k so i've only
i've lost a factor of k in my
approximation but that's it
um and
now the tree edges have stretch one
and the off tree edges are getting their
stretches divided by k because i've made
the tree edges that you're routing them
over k times larger
and so the upshot was that now
um i've gotten total stretch instead of
being m is m over k
uh plus some logs
at the logic of a total stretch
and that's a major win right so now this
is our our big win here was it by
scaling stuff up i've allowed myself to
divide all the structures by k which
makes the number of edges i need go way
down
right because now the total stretch is
like m over k log n so the number of
editing sample is m over k poly log m
which is exactly what we wanted right so
the
condition number of k
uh we get exactly what we started we get
an approximation ratio of k with m plus
and n minus one plus m over k polynomial
damages so let me just kind of gesture
this a little more before i move on
you know what was the point the point
was if i give you a sub graph
of a graph it's smaller like i get the
left hand side type inequality because i
just removed edges if i scale edges up
it makes the graph bigger but if i scale
i just by a factor of a thousand i've
only made everything at most a thousand
times bigger so when i scale the tree
off by a factor of k
i've made the tree i've at most you know
gotten a k approximation but then when i
try to sparsify this graph using the
tree now the total stretch has fallen
off by
well the tree stayed the same the tree
still stretches itself by one but each
off free edge now gets divided by the
length instead of rounding it over an
edge of same length one you're rounding
over an edge of length k
and so you have a you have a denominator
of k in each of the stretches
so that lets you divide the number of
the probability so each edge that you
samples and off tree edge gets sampled
with a one over k factor better lower
probability which makes the number of
edges fall off by one over k
and then that exactly gives us what we
promised
so
that now actually puts everything
together so now we have
exactly yes
so i did not follow this at all are you
increasing
keeping the number of vertices the same
but changing the number of edges or are
you changing the weights without
changing the edges or is the resistance
so i'll think of this as two steps start
with our original graph
original graph uh that we're trying to
spark we're going to try to construct
the we're trying to construct this
incremental sparsifier so we're trying
to construct a graph with n minus one
plus n over k polynomial edges that is a
k approximation of our graph
the way we're going to do that is we're
first to take our graph
and make it
um and blow up some edges so take the
tree and scale them images so take every
we're going to fix take a nice low
stretch spanning tree and take all of
their weights and multiply them by k
okay so now this goes down yes right so
now the resistance over those edges goes
down because
they're now something the stretch the
stretch over if the stretch was a
hundred when i rounded it over end of
length one that means the path was a
blade 100. if i now right over an edge
of length
a thousand then it's now a hundred over
a thousand it's now 0.1 so what i've
done is i've scaled i've made a new
graph
that now has by blowing up this tree now
the stretch over all the edges and over
edges in the tree is much smaller so the
effective resistances are much better
and then if i sample on that graph
you know all these off tree edges are
now getting sampled with one over k
times smaller probability
did that make sense
and so that lets us that's where this m
over k is coming from
um yeah so i'm on my last slide so the
point is this gives us exactly what we
need for a chain of preconditioners with
kappa is
poly log n
um okay so this results with
all the details i stepped under the rug
all the numerical analysis and the
construction of luxury spanning trees
putting that all together you actually
this is exactly what we said we needed
for
um this gives us exactly our chain of
preconditions right it exactly said
that we can that we can get with the
kappa being this is the stretch in our
spanning trees
and so
the upshot was that now when i put that
back into my previous recursion theorem
we get
um the promised sound so again the the
high level structure and then the
details high level structure take a
graph uh eliminate almost all of its
edges so i think
uh m
o but m o uh tree plus m over poly log n
edges
uh i claim that this incremental sparse
fire construction lets you do that at a
with a uh
but your new graph approximates your old
one within a polylog k factor
um given that you get this chain of
repeatedly doing this where you have to
solve a bunch of linear systems that are
much much smaller
and
that is what gives us the recurrence
that we're solving um then to do that
the main construction was to construct a
graph that
these incremental sparks attire is a
graph that's almost a tree but is a
pretty good approximation the way we did
that was we scaled up some edges to make
we had a low stretch spanning tree which
made each nothing too long scaled stuff
down
scaled the tree up so that now the
effective resistances are
very small and then did sampling did
just effective resistance sampling to
get this very sparse graph
and that was it
and putting that together gives us an m
polylogin algorithm so okay that was a
little compressed at the end but
actually the full structure of an
algorithm uh in my next talk i will give
a algorithm that doesn't use any of this
and i can give the full proof form
that will work in
uh
okay thanks
um
i